i keep telling you it's a cryptocurrency
you can trade
for conventional money oh so it's a
hustle
yeah it's awesome
elon musk hosted an out of this world
saturday night live
alongside a musical guest miley cyrus
maybe it never goes exactly how i think
it's going to but somehow it always ends
up being better
the tech billionaire seemed like an odd
choice to many fans of the sketch comedy
series
now i think if i just posted that on
twitter i'd be fine
his social media posts have raised
eyebrows over the years
which elon made light of during the
monologue to anyone i've offended
i just want to say i reinvented electric
cars and i'm sending people to mars in a
rocket ship
did you think i was also going to be a
chill normal dude
in fact jokes about his eccentric
persona
and popular tech inventions grab some of
the night's
biggest laughs leron i thought you was
the electric
horse guy yeah isn't that yours plugged
in outside
what else got a shout out the unorthodox
name of
elon and girlfriend grime's one-year-old
son
snl is also a great way to learn
something new about the host for example
this is my son's name
it's pronounced cat running across
keyboard
grimes later popped up in this sketch
parodying the world of nintendo
portraying iconic video game character
princess peach
you and i we never sleep
i never attach him under
miley later shared this pic with grimes
and wrote quote
she's not a princess she's a queen and
in lieu of the opening sketch
miley belted a stunning cover of dolly
parton's
light of a clear blue morning
[Music]
[Music]
in between the performance we got plenty
of funny moments with the cast
who brought along their moms for the
special episode
i'm so happy you're here mom me too
boy
miley later gave thanks to two of the
most important women in her life
happy mother's day to my godmother and
to my mom
miley has gushed about what makes a
relationship with her mom
so special like we just always have been
really honest
if like me my mom want to fight we fight
we scream at each other it's like we
have a real relationship it's not like
oh this is my mom i have to be fake
because that should be the person you're
the most real with
[Music]